[Music]
today we're going to we're going over
tactics just tactics first this is my
third class first class we did pinning
then we do it did double attacks now
we're gonna do a related subject called
unguarded men all these examples are
taken from the game of chess by Tarrasch
published in America in 1935 but it's
it's a very good book and he has great
examples so let me read to you what he
says about unguarded men whenever
possible all men should be guarded the
safest guard is by means of pawns we've
all heard that right
unguarded men are frequently a source of
disadvantage sometimes they are attacked
while at the same time another threat is
developed
sometimes they facilitate an annoying
pin or even a double attack so it's
related to those other two ideas we
already went over a few examples will
make the circumstances clear so all the
examples you'll see unguarded men and
the other side takes advantage of it to
win the game so this is our first
example up on the board it's white to
play and I would ask the audience to
tell me which men are unguarded it's
white to win so let's look at the black
side
right now in addition to that piece
which is the unguarded man notice that
there's a piece a couple pieces that may
not be there defended only one time and
that gives us some opportunities also so
what pawn or piece is only defended once
in blacks position the knight and then
what else right and notice the other
tactical element that we're going to
take advantage of notice how the queen
is on a direct line for the bishop and
if only we could get rid of that pawn
and get the knight out of the way we can
wipe out the bishop so those are the
ideas who sees the winning move for
white now in this case winning is
defined not winning a piece so don't
look for that or a checkmate
we may win a lousy pawn out of a deal
that's absolutely the right move so now
we're lined up we have our queen the
pawns out of the way the Queen's on the
bishop now we did have to leave our
white scored Bishop unprotected but we
can do Knight takes Knight check right
he has to do pawn takes Knight and then
we can do Queen takes Bishop so that
would look something like this and
notice in this particular line that the
black King side position is shattered
the g7 pawn is now on f6 and it's
conveniently attacked by our black
scored bishop and our queen which would
line up the Queen and Bishop on the line
toward the King let's call the battery
in chess and threaten Queen the Knights
of and checkmate
it's all over for black in that on top
of that if that's not enough we could
believe bring one of our works to the
Queen Bishop file and threaten rook our
Queen takes pawn and wipe out the c5
pawn - but as long as we can get the
King we might as well go in that
direction but there was a better move
for black in this position rather oh let
me back up a minute rather than Queen
takes bishop that was a bad move
what is the relatively better move for
black your queen is attacked do you have
to deal with that threat before you move
anything else Knight takes Knight that's
the better move so Queen takes Knight
now you see Black has avoided those
double pawns his King side position is
intact he just lost a lousy pawn so now
oh but there's a move for black besides
Queen takes bishop there's a better move
the net what is the better move for
black you're going to lose that Bishop
anyway remember telling yourself if
you're gonna lose the piece you might as
well sell it for what it's worth so why
not sacrifice it where can we sacrifice
the black square bishop yeah Bishop
takes pawn check then we don't actually
lose the pawn do we and King takes why
King takes for our knight takes which is
better
that's true so you might if you were
worried about black attacking the king
you might take with the knight but black
hasn't even moved his rooks they're
hiding behind his pawns right and his
queen is I'm the wrong side to attack
the king is Queens gonna be on b5
blocked by his own pawn and his knight
certainly not going to get over so I
would take with the King because you
want your knight to be able to come into
the center squares and if he somehow
checks your King you just go retreat
back to g1 yeah but the main thing is
that you want to leave your knight where
it impacts the center squares and can
also go up to G Knight to g5 right it
impacts more squares and I suppose you
could even do a maneuver of rook over to
King ruck 1 and bringing the King back
and then you could attack along the King
work file if you wanted to okay so now
Queen takes bishop now the pawns are
even right No
yeah 3 on the Kings side and 2 on the
Queen side but whose pawns are better
blacks or whites why is that
I'm the Queen side and Black's not
connected or protected right so that
pawn on c5 looks really weak to me how
can we how can white win that pawn which
rook
well you picked the wrong rook you pick
the F work they're almost equivalent but
the slight difference is you want to
leave that a Brook they're protecting
the pawn in cases Queen moves to attack
the pawn or the knight moves and could
attack that pawn that would be
undefended now the other work is blocked
in by a pawn too so why not move the
King work over that's the right move and
the move recommended by the author now
notice there's no way black can defend
that pawn and we threatened rook takes
pawn and then what are we threatened we
have a double attack Queen and Knight we
threaten to win the knight this is a
definite your pawn up it's it's not a
winning necessarily a winning position
but it's a bit a pretty good plus for
white okay okay so let's analyze this
position white to play and win now what
what is the most striking element in the
way the pieces are set up for both white
and black would you say that's right
the Queen would be C the King is in
front of the black queen and if we could
just somehow get those Knights out of
the way we might make the King move we
could at least trade Queens maybe
there's some way we can take advantage
of that line
now where's the unprotected pieces for
black that's our theme tonight
unprotected pieces okay go ahead tell me
yeah that's unprotected but before we
focus on pawns let's see what pieces are
unprotected yeah we got lots of them
this time don't we
okay right and what else
bishop on e6 we have a wealth of
unprotected pieces that makes it a
little more complicated to figure out
which one to attack so the answer is we
make a move and attack something and it
makes sense to move one of the Knights
to open up that line for the Queen and
then we would threaten moving the other
night with a discovered check well that
would be a check immediately and the
king would retreat and we wouldn't be
able to do as a discovered attack on the
Queen you see that the King could just
go back to c8 and protect Knight to g6
is a good idea g5 you mean no
Oh Knight to g6 you get the pawn that's
true let's say we did Knight takes g6
what is our follow up threat what would
be the next strong say white could do
two moves in a row what would be whites
winning move after that
I don't see one Knight to g6 is a pretty
good movement there's a stronger move if
you have unprotected pawns and pieces
you want to focus on attacking an
unprotected piece which piece can we
attack with one of our Knights well look
okay let's look at it this way those
Knights are on black squares right
they're going to move to a white square
now we said there's three pieces that
are unprotected two of them are on white
squares the knight can't move and attack
those two pieces that it can't attack
the bishop on e6 or the work on h7 can
it it has to attack the last piece the
knight
what's the move
that's absolutely correct
congratulations it's very important that
it's the d6 night why the d6 night and
not the e5 night
that is not quite yet notice that one of
the Knights can move and attack the
Queen but only one night what Knight can
move and attack the Queen in the future
right and he can go to two squares to
attack the Queen and notice that it
would be a discovered check and
attacking the Queen at the same time and
if the King took the knight it would
leave the Queen unprotected and if the
King moves the knight takes the Queen so
the only answer is you have to do the
knight on d6 to allow the other night to
attack the Queen so that's why night to
see Knight on d6 to c4 is the winning
move so this wins he can't protect the
knight and he doesn't have time to
retreat it because our next move so
let's just say he does Knight takes
Knight our next move is night here
discovered check he has to do King takes
Knight and we do Queen takes Queen now
he got two nights for the Queen but
notice our queen is attacking that pawn
on b7 and we have more than an end
we are also threatening the e4 pawn
takes the pawn on f5 opening up the
bishop line then the bishop can join in
the attack on the king and the knight
and notice that that rook looks pretty
scrumptious over in the corner Queen
takes pawn check King moves will
Queen takes rook we get a strong attack
yeah so anyway that's the end of that
one okay let's try our next example this
one in this position you might be
puzzled out it's black to play black to
win but not to play and when first the
author has white make a blunder so you
won't see anything in this position let
me make the blunder he wants to come he
wants to complete his development he
castles now what's the unprotected piece
what's what could potentially attack the
bishop what's blocking the rook okay
what's the winning move to win a pod why
not Knight to d5 and take the pawn that
you want to win if you Knight to f5 I
can retreat the Queen and protect the
bishop if you take the pawn and I
retreat the Queen you are still pawn up
so the answer is very simply Knight
takes pawn and that's all there is to
this example but a cute little way to
take advantage of an unprotected piece
okay and this one is tricky I've been
through these so that's I've been
through all of them but this is tricky
let's just talk about it's black to play
and win let's talk about first of all
the King position which King looks safer
to you the black King or the white King
the black King it's hiding it's well
protected by a pawn on h7 the black
Queen protects it and the Black Knight
on h5 protects it that white King should
be over there at g2 hiding behind his
pawns or h2 maybe so the King is stuck
in the middle the board where he's open
to attacks
what can't look at the
now let's talk about the aggressive
placement of the relative pieces well
let's start with the pawns first do they
have the same number of pawns white is
too extra right that black has five and
white is seven however notice how white
spawns are far advanced when Pau every
time a pawn moves forward they leave
open squares behind them into the side
and around them
notice that the queen Knight file is
open and that black conveniently has two
rooks doubled up that's a very strong
attacking position for two rooks isn't
it
the rook is ready to come down and
invade the second row by rook to be two
at an opportune moment so keep that
factor in mind notice that the white
bishop is what we would say not well
placed it can't move forward it's
blocked by its own pawn on d5 but even
worse than that it blocks the black King
so that bishop on c4 is a problem for
white it's it's not helpful okay
now White's rooks see how blacks rooks
are attacking and can't invade blacks
position White's rook one is behind a
pawn the other is blocked by the king
the only thing they're doing are
defending the first and second rows so
relatively speaking the black rooks have
a big advantage over the white rooks
white is in a purely defensive posture
that's what you want when you're
attacking black is attacking he has
forced white on the defense so even
though he's two pawns down black has
strong attacking chances now we haven't
talked about the black knight if given
the opportunity the Black Knight is an
attacking position to not just defending
the King what is the black
attacking f4 but that is protected by a
pawn what pawn is not protected by any
other pawn that the naked g3 okay so
look we might be able to play Knight
takes g3 and threaten the rook on h1 at
some right okay anyway these are all the
elements to think about is we solve this
problem right now that's true so one of
the ideas when you're attacking is there
a way to trick the Queen to moving away
from protecting the pond I'm g3 or
divert the Queen in some other fashion
black could do start off with Queen f5
check right there look the King can't
retreat to c2 which wouldn't be good
anyway because the record gonna be to
check so the king would have to go over
to e1 e2 but before we jump into this
further let's talk about unprotected
pieces with a theme of tonight
what White's pieces are in protective
just work right now but this gentleman
said Queen if I check and if our King
goes to e2 that now we suddenly have
another piece unprotected bishop on c4
now we have two unprotected pieces there
might be some combination to take
advantage of the fact that those are
unprotected and take advantage of the
fact that the queen is protecting g3 and
also defending the center squares you
see that now we remember black suite is
now on f5 and the White King is on e2
but before we go into the King retreat
there's an easy you want what this is
the right move we hear check so what
happens if the Queen blocks the chip
you take with the Queen and King takes
914 correct and King taking advantage of
the unprotected piece say so the queen
is overworked here you see how the queen
is trying to defend would like to defend
against the Queen if I check but she has
to continue to protect g3 so the queen
is overworked now that should give you
some good follow ups this is the main
line King back
what's the winning move for black mean
one move takes a couple moves okay I
would say bring the rope down the b1 the
Queens protecting it if he moves this
rook over you got what if he does sure
it takes Rick my mother well you can
take it back with either the queen of
rook but I don't see an immediate win
and you saw one of White's problem is he
no longer has an unprotected rook I'm H
1 SC 1 so that that's not the winning
idea like Knight to g3 yes that's the
idea it diverts the Queen from
protecting the center squares Queen
takes now what happens
can we attack the work and Bishop with a
piece in addition at the same time he
and the key yep what's the move Queen e4
we need to e4 check did you see how we
diverted the Queen away from protecting
the e4 square and that now we can take
advantage of the two unprotected pieces
and we win at least an exchange but the
finish is kind of humor so let me call
the author's finish because it's rather
nice actually
okay wait a minute wait wait in Queen
here okay wait here Quetta III Queen
takes work
okay where he takes Rick d6 he wants to
open up a line for the Queens to check
and try to shove that pawn and you get
threatened to get a queen right so
that's all a good fine
now we invade with our double Brooks
remember I told you that was a strong
attack II work down there okay now he
plays east seven now he just threatened
pawn up Queen check but it's too slow
rook takes rook check Queen takes if
King takes what happens look to be beat
you
King to d3 and Queen to d1 checkmate
so Queen takes Queen to e4 check look we
take advantage of that unprotected
bishop it's a like a reflection move or
repeat boob we bring our queen back and
get the same double attack now we pick
up the bishop and the Queen has been
diverted from e3 and pawn up is no
longer threatening and when a queen so
that's kind of a nice finish and if
Queen messes up and goes to e 380 check
with the rook and lose your queen good
point
so anyway what was butchered fairly
while there yeah okay oh this is real
simple it's based on the author likes to
have the opponent make of blunders start
yet so I have to make the blender and
then not see Bishop takes pawn what's
the winning move with the seal which
work
oh you doing that to me again yeah
you see if you can guess which rook is
the correct absolutely correct why is
that better than the other work that's
true but there's a better reason that
Bishop can move and attack a rook if you
leave it on f1 Kanaks then he it's true
we went to pieces but we could win up
but we lose the rook so by moving the F
work
there's no Bishop to d3 attacking
anything we want a whole piece so that's
the one the correct rook there is no
defense
notice that d2 is covered by our black
squared bishop so that's the end of the
story of black in a perfectly good
position till he lined up his bishops
and flip the rook attack both of them
okay let's move on to the next one black
the move and blunder this is obvious
what's the winning move for a white what
are the unprotected pieces and what else
that's true now
what piece can attack both those
unprotected pieces in one move
please wear what square does the Queen
go to you're absolutely right but what's
the square it's the a file a 4 a 4
that's absolutely right
notice we attacked the bishop and the
rook and once on a black square ones on
a white square they can't protect each
other so we want to be some gia which
which others gonna go well if I was
black I decided to resign I protect my
record move it but I think I've resigned
the humiliation over and I drag it out
making making play mark for the next one
alright next one see if this is based
oh this one this one doesn't lead to the
loss of a piece it leads to a bad
position for white so it's not as
exciting as what we've looked at and it
takes a couple moves to get into it so
first black plays c3 protecting his d5
pawn and opening a line for his Queen
right now he white makes a bad move rook
to e2 very conveniently putting the rook
in unprotected status right now the
other pieces in protected is the bishop
on e4
there's no way to immediately attack
them but we can get ready to attack them
with this move Queen to b6 it threatens
the pawn on b2 and a queen can attack
the bishop and the RIC the next move by
Queen the a6 so white moves the bishop
to protect upon black attacks the two
pieces in this case because they're both
on white squares there is a move where
one piece
we protect the other one right okay so
this is the end and the positional
disadvantage is who would want a bishop
on d1 blocked by Oregon the e2 and the
bishop on d1 blocks the work on a 1 in
the meantime black has his two bishops
out his Queens out and black can bring a
work to the King file and preparing it
up a rooks and initiate a strong attack
then that Bishop id3 can never move once
we get double rooks so black has a much
better position but he's not a partner
of Pisa why would white hand move their
Bishop to e3
considering the basically because he
wanted a way to protect the pawn on B to
C they quit the threat is Queen takes b2
now the only and he can't do work to be
won cuz there's a white square bishop on
that squirt there and he didn't he
couldn't block him bishop in with pond
of b3 cuz then Y could play b5 at some
point and trap the bishop he could try
beef before though those things but
anyway that then the authors example
would work on everything so that's why
okay I think we got one more might as
well go through it before we wrap up
okay okay it's white to move and win now
let's look at the position are the pawns
even
numerically they argue whose ponds are
in the more aggressive position whiter
by blacks clearly in a defensive
position isn't it black does have a
well-placed
rook on e8 attacking that pawn on e4 of
course the pawns protected by the
bishops of there's no threat by black to
win the pond and the white work on that
one can slide over to e1 if need be and
reinforce the part so clearly white is
in the attacking position black spawn
structure doesn't look that bad other
than being purely defensive
notice that the pawns are only on the
second and third row of blacks position
that's a defensive setup white pawns are
all the way to the fourth row that's an
aggressive setup he's attacking squares
and black side of the board with his
pawns and he keeps all the black pieces
out of the center of the board
now for the work Black has a pawn
weakness what's the bond weaknesses
black can't g6 okay
those two pawns in front of each other
where did they call one one pond at c6
one and c7 what are they called in chess
he looks like a double pawn okay
remember double bonds are weak if that
pawn on c6 was back on b7 black could
play the pawn on c7 up one square to c6
and the pawn on b7 would protect you
have a nice pawn chain and it would
block the white square bishop you see
that but because that pawns on c6 is in
double no pawn can protect that pawn on
c6 that pawn is a weakness we're going
to figure out a way to attack that far
now the logical piece to attack the pawn
is fish
city 9g - what's in the way of the
bishop attacking the park
efore yeah so let's just throw that up
one square and we sacrifice a pawn but
we threaten Bishop takes pawn and once
we get our Bishop to c6 what's our
threats you're pinning tonight I'm
pinning the night and I threatened
Bishop takes Knight right and notice
that the work on d1 along with a pawn on
e5 is attacking the pawn on d6 threatens
to win the pawn pawn takes pawn takes
rook takes pawn then I have our work and
a bishop on that night would night that
looks like elements of a combination I
might not win the piece maybe I can win
a pawn out of the prefer my troubles
so we already said ich e5 which is the
right move now what do you think black
should do here
the Ephesus where to take d5 okay that's
that's the main line so we'll go to that
in a second there's some alternative
defense black can track if your font is
attacked now whites at threatening to
win two pawns you can try to block the
bishop with a pawn move at the same time
you would remove the pawn on d6 from
being attacked what move is that d5
right here now it looks like black safe
he's got a pawn chain directed at the
bishop it looks like there's nothing for
the bishop to do now and he saved the
pond it's no longer on d6 there's no
threat and black is threatening pawn
takes pawn pawn takes pawn in basan
basan only works if the black pawn were
on d7 or the knight is and you move it
two squares
oh yeah if the pawn is on the fifth like
the white pawn but it in Cassatt is
French for in passing and it means that
if the pawn moves two squares white gets
to treat the pawn as if it had only
moved one and he can take it there but
kiss the pawns already on T six it
doesn't apply in that case but there's a
drawback to d5 how can we attack that
pawn with another piece of cloth the
pawn on d5 now the double move from the
sea the sea fort right so let's shove
that up there now look there's pawn
takes pawn rook takes pawn our Bishop
takes pawn check team over then we can
still pin the night and we'd open up the
line of the rook and wait in the mission
but on that night there's no way to
defend it d5 doesn't work because c4 is
such a good move that you found okay so
now we go to the main line F takes
what's the next move for wife yeah
Bishop takes pawn now what does black
dude yes she moved the room tonight
and where should he move it well you
would move the rook that knight is
pinned against so you had moved the rook
on e8 it wouldn't make sense to move the
other rook I could pin it I could drop
the fish back and pin it against the
king and then I would wanna fish it for
I work for a bishop so it has to be
either rook to e7 or work the DA right
does it make a difference where the
witch square the work force dude yes I
think you're increasing here you're
playing on the field of the rock I agree
with you but I will say that in this
particular example it doesn't make a
difference and the reason is white takes
the knight so the right that's right
then you would be right so he takes and
the work ends up by d7 anyway so in this
example it worked either Square would
end up in the same now notice that the
pawn on d6 is pinned is it not
he can't deploy so we take the pawn it
looks like we went apply but black has a
defense rook takes check now if I do
Rick takes he does pawn takes pawn and
he's defended he has three pawns and I'm
the queen say well he has three four
five pawns and white has five points so
we take with the King because I want the
rook is stronger on Queen one than f1 so
I think with the King Egyptian rejects
me to get out of the pin now I get my C
I get my King up to a good safe squared
King to g2 notice how it protects
all the entry points on the F file it
protects f3 f2 and f1 White's King is
better placed than blacks which is stuck
back on g8 behind the pawns and the rook
you see that
okay now blankets his pawn got watched
what happens this is really cool you
check check the room work just now what
did you come up a a square in wind a
pond right here to d7 right that doesn't
work because Oh didn't you just go back
it just goes back he just moves back to
F supp yeah yeah alright so the right
move is to go to King and pawn ending
it's a one King and pawn ending so you
take the book now look who's pawns are
weak or white or blacks they're black
has three isolated pawns doesn't whites
pawns are protected on both the king and
queen side that's enough for white to
win the nd it's kind of nicer what we're
in third Oh quick also the King is
closer to the pawns by one move to say
that okay now he could go to it but
white black King could go to e6 or d6
the author has to go to d6 so he can
protect the pawn on c7 so it goes there
now there's only one move for white to
win the King and bought any who sees the
winning move it's tricky
that's what you would think but that's
not the right answer
the problem with pawn to c4 notice that
the black pawn could move to c5 and
block our beep on for moving to b4 and
then the white the black pawn on c7 can
move to a5 and even if I play a three I
can't move the pawn the p4 that would be
a drawn King and pawn and the clever
move which I admit I might not have seen
this if I didn't read the answer is
before now he can't play c5 because it
would be pawn takes pawn he king takes
King pawn and then I have an extra pawn
and I can shove the pawn up the King
black King retreats then at some point I
can shoot my team over to e6 f7 and wipe
out the team side pawns he doesn't have
time to get my rook pawn and I shoved
one of my pawns and get a queen and one
me ND so c5 doesn't work so he plays a6
to prevent the pawns are moving forward
now I play a four I'm getting ready to
show my pawn to c4 and then I can get a
passed pawn on the Queen side
blackstein's gonna have to go over there
to stop the past pawn I take the King
pawn and I move my King and wipe out his
two pawns on the Kings side so there
yeah now what else could he do if he
plays c5 I haven't put my pawn to b5 and
I have two pawns against I am a passed
pawn right away you see that cuz the
pawn can go to b6 and b7 so c5 doesn't
work because I had moved my pawn to b5
if he moves
the kingside bonds well the the g6 palm
won't work because I could go King to f5
an attack the pawns
similarly moving the H pawn doesn't
really help if he moves to h5 I can move
my apartment h4 and then I he has to
move his King somewhere and I could get
my past pawn on the Queen side and then
I could still walk over and get the King
site phones you getting into judgment
yeah so anyway people 85 and here's how
it goes
King takes pawn oh and this is where he
stops because obviously look he can't
even do King takes c4 right because he
would leave the a5 pawn could go to e6
and notice that the King can't block the
a6 pawn because he can't retreat to b6
so he can retreat to c6 but then he's
not threatening anybody and I just moved
my king over to f6 and wipe out the two
pawns of the keys and that covers our
topic unprotected pieces so the role the
story is always try to protect your
pieces preferably with pawns if not with
pawns with other pieces and if you have
to leave one hanging around make sure
there aren't any combinations against
[Music]
you